quelqu'un sonne à la porte j'ai une
série reconnecter justin touché des
panneaux je peux ouvrir s'est reconnecté
que tous les produits sont intégrés dans
rappelle-t-il
[Musique]
m
on est avec philippe donat nolifes
directement sur zone d'un non-lieu
prononcé bien je dis pas que derrière
canadienne qui permet d'allier vraiment
la maison connectée avec de la lumière
tout ça avec de la neige artificielle du
google phone by amazon avec ça il faut
avoir un résultat des correctifs de la
lumière qui comment tu pourrais finir à
côté design c'est moitié design moitié
lumière connectés ouais voilà on est
on se différencie vraiment sur ce côté
modulaire design qui permet de faire des
choses très très jolie pour son
appartement
ouais c'est super beau alors est ce que
tu peux me présenter le produit de base
comprend mieux comment ça marche
tu vois tout ça qui m'a finalement en
fait on le présente comme un dégoût de
lumière voilà une pièce de lumière en
fait c'est un produit modulaire l'aide
ce qui s'imbriquent les uns dans les
autres on canalise zorn dernier carré
elle est en fait ce produit vous permet
de créer la forme que vous voulez oh
quel est votre récemment et donc faire
quelque chose de joli et ensuite de
connecter aux politiques bénéficier de
toutes les collectivités wihda bank et
prévient de contrôleurs dans les salles
permet de bénéficier de toutes les
fonctionnalités de la maison connectée
[Musique]
on a une installation qui tourne en fait
27 panneaux et sally pearson
on a des petites cartes sim ici qui
s'imbriquent jetant chaque triangle
center est en fait je suis juste posé et
voilà il est connecté et il va récupérer
au bout de quelques secondes il va
récupérer le
le pattern on va dire le design du
koller qui en place ça veut dire que tu
le prends tu le connais qui juste et lui
il va récupérer tout ce qui est en train
de se passer à ce que voulaient défini
dans l'app la grotte est définie par
d'autres méthodes
par exemple ok google mail
en bleu ok ils veulent récupérer
directement en connectant au bout de
douze le pas de limites nous notre corps
ses 1200 panneau est en vue la seule
limite c'est l'alimentation puisqu'au
bout d'un certain moment tu peux faire
de mieux résister à l'étude 35
on recommande de rajouter une
alimentation et de 35 panneaux là il ya
c'est une belle installation de panneaux
ça commence à porter ses sages et le
génois ok génial alors qu'est ce que tu
peux faire d'autre à ce cas
effectivement on voit qu'il ya un côté
hyper décoratifs qui change de lumière
donc on voit qu'on est vraiment dans
l'objet décoratif lumière connecté à la
maison qu'est ce qu'on a comme kde
usages alors opposant pro cutter healy à
ses côtés décoratifs qui permet
qui permet aux gens qui ne sont pas très
portés sur les technologies de ne pas
avoir utilisé l'ap
ils doivent utiliser les boutons qui
sont sur le produit et peuvent passer
les différentes couleurs les gens en
mode si vous voulez aller plus loin on
peut aller dans l'app et là on peut
ventoux ferias
il ya 17 millions de couleurs là on est
connecté à
l'installation derrière moi on l'a
différentes scènes qui sont prédéfinis
par nano itx
bien sûr on peut créer sa propre scène
voilà en sélectionnant ici là j'ai juste
changé de seine pour nous montrer donc
là on passe sur nîmes au voile à orange
et blanc comme comme dessin animé on
peut aller sur romantique par exemple
voilà donc la cdm où on prône
l'installation comme un ensemble complet
si on veut aller plus loin
on veut atteindre vraiment prendre
l'option de dessiner je veux m youtube
com ou la voilà on va ont choisi une
palette de couleurs est là on va pas
nous par panneaux par exemple je fais ça
je sélectionne et voyez derrière moi ça
réagit les panneaux change de couleur au
fur et à mesure
et donc on peut jouer sur les couleurs
en plus que sur le mode de variation
l'intensité on peut jouer sur la vitesse
de variations aussi on peut vraiment
tout faire c'est que ce taux monte à 100
l'adn de ce produit c'est vraiment de
personnaliser son altération d'intérieur
des gens qui est jean qu'ils achètent
ils l'utilisent quoi plus pour des
pièces de renom on a beaucoup beaucoup
de quatre différents on a les gens qui
l'achètent pour décorer un salon par
exemple toute la zone 8 août aux côtés
life style design beaucoup de gamers de
lemmings parce qu'on est compatible avec
le raider et cooler master notamment
les lumières réagir aux jeux vidéo
l'implication d'un coup
qui achète de contenu pour ça et on a
aussi tout parti
walt natio gars des salles de yoga qui
de qt et bien sûr des restaurants des
bars
la découpe prodeco donc et comme on a
sorti une application musique
l'année dernière on a pas mal de boîte
de nuit et que vous
un petit micro qui dans ce petit module
là et en fait ça va réagir à la musique
et donc vous voyez vos lumières danser
sur la musique et on ça crée une
ambiance assez cool à ces boîtes de nuit
donc ça c'est le produit que vous avez
sorti l'année dernière
oui voilà et là tu es un nouveau produit
cette année en cette année en annonce
initiale bas qui sont lancés
officiellement le 1er décembre à travers
le monde pour noël noël rappeler et
qui seront aussi compatibles à peu
l'homme qui
amazon et
c'est déclaré prendre différentes
l'optique est différente à petit
attractif le rendu est différent les
fonctionnalités sont les mêmes la brosse
la grosse innovation c'est eux sont
tactiles donc on peut on peut les
contrôler via nous toucher par exemple
je fais ça
ça change le mode comme tout à l'heure
j'ai changé les modes avec l'ap
là on peut le faire simplement en
touchant
les panneaux on peut faire bien sûr duo
nov on peut changer la couleur on peut
faire pas mal de choses il ya des
applications sur lesquelles on
moss parce que c'est un objet connecté
donc il est combattu par exemple apple
au titre donc on peut se dire
quelqu'un sonne à la porte j'ai une
serrure collectif justin touché des
panneaux je peux ouvrir s'est reconnecté
que tous les produits sont intégrés dans
apple optique
voilà on est en train de bosser là
dessus pour l'intégrer complètement la
maison connectée et rendre sa le mode de
contrôle que le plus facile ça veut dire
que juste avec ton mur de contrôle
lumineux qui travaillent quels éléments
décoratifs
tu as puis tu peux a signé un élément
une action et ça ne l'a fait grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle
voilà exactement c'est génial contrôler
sa maison connectée rien qu'avec le
toucher on pourra dans l'app définit
ainsi
un appui non c'est juste une ouverture
de porte 3a qui courent ça peut être je
sais pas mon thermostat net atmo certain
degré il faut pas être le soir fatigué
gens jetaient sur truc la mort qui
change la température c'est la csbf et
25 l'année 30 pêche comme en rien un
écho voilà enfin faudra être un peu
précis mais c'est les applications sur
lesquelles on peut bosser c'est génial
si peu que ce qu'on a appris sur l'acte
notre télécommande en fait voilà c'était
des commandes que la sortie en juin
elle appelle la même chose en fait
chaque phase c'était un scénario de la
maison connectée
donc on lui dira par exemple la suite
c'était mes lumières en rouge
mon thermostat sur 20 degrés et mes
volets à chaque fois qu'on tournait
quand on le produit commis sur 8 par
exemple sacré s'activent le scénario du
bain là on aura le même principe avec le
toucher c'est génial ok alors tu me dis
j'ai compris acquise dessiner le produit
j'ai compris ce qu'on pouvait faire
est ce que aujourd'hui était puni si
c'est un disque et non pas contre est ce
que c'est un produit qui fonctionne bien
ce vrai bien il ya vraiment un grand
gagnant derrière ouais on peut
marche en marche très bien on développe
vient d'ouvrir cette année le bureau
parisien pour l'europe vaut plus un truc
pas mal de gens et
en se développant et
très actif on peut vous trouver ou deux
produits une valeur actuellement en
france vous l'avez dans les apple stores
chez boulanger ligne bien sûr sur amazon
sur notre site vous maintiendra
description aussi valable dans tout ça
les viandes et dans certaines boutiques
un peu un peu trahi comme la fondation
nous dit on par exemple et voilà
enfin au bon marché dans des
les magasins comme ça qui est cool alors
autant de tarifs rendez vous alors on
est sur 199 le kit de démarrage avec 9
999 euros
c'est le cas être une entente avec ceux
qui tueraient toutes les fonctionnalités
accuse notamment la partie rhythm la
partie musique et pareil pour les pour
les quarts et pour lesquels 20 ils
viendront à 199 euros le 1er décembre et
après on peut rajouter des kits
d'extension est allé jusqu'à trente
quarante panneaux grâce au kit extension
qui sont vendus pour les triangles par
trois et pour les quarts et par 6 litres
merci brown j'adore c'est super joli
gens super six si vous en avez en trop
je viens d'apprendre qu'il revient à la
fin et ça lui coûte suffit à vous
félicitations je ne suis pas juriste
voit ce qui se passe quand je trouve
vraiment intéressant parce que vous en
pensez en commentaire c'est vraiment
voir comment on peut allier les éléments
décoratifs la maison connectée la
lumière connectés donc c'est vraiment un
sens dit quoi vous ce que vous en pensez
comme moi ce que vous verriez ça quel
cas d'usagé quand vous pourrez utiliser
chez vous il était sûr à marquer tout ça
un commentaire to
[Musique]